retrouvons michel fize sociologue
bonsoir michel fize merci d'être avec
nous vous avez certainement vu michel
fize ces images en direct
images de violence d'une manifestation
qui était calme au début qui dégénère
comme souvent quelle est votre première
réaction
que savait le mouvement des gilets
jaunes a révélé qu'ils avaient un énorme
problème dans ce pays un problème d'
injustice un problème de discrimination
un problème de relation et plus
exactement de mauvaises relations entre
les citoyens et une partie une partie de
la police donc la crise sanitaire n'a
pas fait oublier à sa tombe de combat
qui était commencée avant et qu'ils
reprennent maintenant qu'on est sorti de
la phase la plus aiguë de 7 2 7 de cette
pandémie
moi ces images me faisait penser plus
spécifiquement aux images américaine que
l'on voit actuellement bon pour un fait
d'ailleurs assez similaire bon mettant
en cause bon à tort ou à raison mais
apparemment à raison à un policier donc
ça veut dire que c'est le monde qui
souffrent le monde je crois
il est aujourd'hui dans une position de
tolérance zéro voyez ce type d'affaires
il ya 20 ou 30 ans aurait été enterré et
puis on serait passé à autre chose voilà
eh bien je pense que aujourd'hui les
gens n'oublient pas voilà cette affaire
adama traoré n'est pas résolu et je
pense pour reprendre une expression très
gilet jaune que effectivement on ne
lâchera rien un du côté des défenseurs
de cette cause
mais je suis vous faisiez allusion au
gilet jaune est ce qu'on peut vraiment
finalement faire une comparaison entre
ce qui est en train de se passer devant
le tribunal judiciaire et les gilet
jaune
vous avez effectivement fait la
comparaison avec les états unis est ce
qu'on n'est pas justement dans ce
registre là d'une police qu'on accuse
parfois voilà selon certains de de
racisme
on parle également pour les détracteurs
de violences policières est ce que ce
n'est pas justement pas le même combat
avec les gilet jaune
je pense qu'il ya des il ya des ya des
coïncidences entre tous ces combats
d'ailleurs on peut penser par ming que
ces personnes qui sont dans la rue il y
à des ex idée gilet jaune qui viendront
peut-être dans quelques mois de futurs
de futurs gilet jaune
je pense qu'on a une société qui était
éclatée qui est socialement fracturé de
tous les côtés plus rien ne va nulle
part donc tout explose un effectivement
un foyer d'incendié ce soir demain ce
sera probablement un autre à notre
incendie parce que les problèmes qui
sont sur la table les problèmes de
discrimination les problèmes
vous disiez de violences policières sont
des problèmes récurrents depuis depuis
une trentaine d'années la question
d'ailleurs des banlieues 1 le traitement
des banlieues n'a jamais été effectué
malgré l'argent qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
distribuer bons la question des du
personnel soignant des moyens qui font
défaut n'est pas résolu la question des
avocats avec la paupérisation de cette
profession n'est pas résolu et j'allais
dire le problème des policiers eux-mêmes
qui se groupent d'ailleurs hadoop
situation d'être à la fois quelques fois
auteur et victime
globalement les policiers sont aussi des
personnes qui manquent de moyens qui
manquent d'effectifs qui manquent de
matériel voyez donc on fait ensuite on a
souvent commenté ces après midi les
jaunes l'ensemble sur ce plateau vous
étiez l'un de nos invités on disait
souvent justement que le combat des
régions ne s'était pas vraiment le
combat voilà des banlieues et cette
manifestation semble davantage justement
sur ce registre là on le rappelle le
comité adama traoré
on parle de déni de justice a third
adama traoré qui parle de déni de
justice ce sont des problèmes qui se
superposent les uns sur les autres
alors superposition ou additions
activement les combats s'additionnent
les uns les autres à la recherche peut
être pour le moment d'une improbable
convergence un car ce combat qui
pourrait être un combat unique contre la
paupérisation contre la discrimination
contre l'éclatement sociales et bien
pour le moment ce sont des combats
catégoriels pour le plus souvent c'est
telles catégories d'un côté telle
catégorie de l'autre et puis bon pour ce
qui concerne les faits il est fait de ce
soir bon ça nous met effectivement face
à une société bon dont on sait qu'elles
n'intègrent plus est d'abord elle
n'intègre plus par le travail et elle
est encore sous le coup du racisme de la
xénophobie d'un certain nombre de
violences avait ça fait longtemps que je
parle des difficiles relations entre
entre les policiers et en particulier à
particulier les jeunes
bassett cette situation n'a pas été
résolue donc le problème en france c'est
que on ne prend un dossier à bras le
corps que quand le feu est la dap tête
avec l'étincelle de ce soir qu'il y aura
une réflexion sur la question de la
fonction policière du rôle de la police
de la déontologie de la police
et j'ajouterais de la formation de la
police à on a peut-être des policiers
manque de formation et puis bon entre
nous il y adeux tension à la fois chez
les auteurs et les victimes on est
d'ordre dans un monde qui ressemble un
volcan tout est en tension de tous les
côtés et donc il ya des pertes de sang
froid de part et d'autre dans des
relations qui finissent par ne plus être
des relations normales voilà où on
dialogue on essaie de trouver des
compromis
1 michel fize justement aujourd'hui la
mousse de l'intérieur est dans une
position il est voilà obligé défense et
police la police qui protège dans ce
pays les femmes et les hommes de tout y
compris du racisme
vous êtes étonné qu'on puisse en arriver
là une police qui est accusée clairement
de racisme aujourd'hui en france ils
savent et je pense qu'on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas évidemment généralisée bon
j'ai dit sur un autre plateau récemment
que la police était raciste
alors je clarifie mon propos il y à des
policiers raciste ou plus exactement
peut-être des policiers qui n'aiment pas
telle ou telle catégorie de population
qui est peut-être effectivement le début
du racisme et enfin on a le droit de ne
pas aimer telle ou telle catégorie de
population sans tomber dans la
discrimination et et dans aida aidants
et dans le racisme
bon il est évident que il ya des études
qui ont été qui ont été faites notamment
par des collègues du cnrs ya une dizaine
d'années qui m'ont très bien qu'il y
avait toujours des discriminations par
rapport aux contrôles d'identité par
exemple que si vous étiez maghrébins ou
de couleur noire vous aviez entre six et
huit fois plus de risques d'être d'être
interpellé que une personne bang
appelons-la blanche comme on dirait
comme on dirait aux attentes aux états
unis bon ça ce sont ce sont des faits ce
sont des faits sur lesquels il faut
apporter des réponses
alors du côté évidemment des auteurs de
ces violences il faut savoir que
beaucoup sont aussi dans des situations
sociales très compliquée par rapport à
ce que
irrité par rapport au travail donc je
précise bien je n'excuse pas les faits
moi je n'ai pas excusé a condamné ou à
me féliciter ici question on a vu ce
panneau au brandies par les manifestants
union et solidarité contre le fascisme
d'état le sociologue que vous êtes est
étonné est-ce que vous avez déjà pu lire
ce genre de pancartes en france
toutes ces dernières années alors le mot
fascisme je ne l'avais pas vu depuis un
certain temps qui avait été plutôt
remplacé par populisme
bon si on va préciser qu un populisme de
droite et un populisme de de gauche mais
ça montre bien qu'il ya aussi des
combats à côté ou à l'intérieur qui sont
aussi des combats politiques des combats
de radicalisation politique qui a un
autre projet de société qui est portée
comme c'était le cas pour les gêner
jaune comme c'était le cas pour les
membres de nuit debout alia il ya quatre
ans bon appelons ça un projet anarchiste
au sens d'une égalité d'une autre façon
de de faire de fer politique une autre
façon de faire société
merci michel fize sociologue d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france